honey at least you got some real shoes
on real shoes not house shoes not
crutches I know God bless you come on
now but you know you've graduated to a
cane yes this is the first this is my
first Venture into uh Kingdom
are y'all over the oh I mean the jokes I
tell you
who was one the one responsible for the
the suit the bubble suit that was uh it
was a fan of it his family yeah yeah oh
my gosh I love it I love it well it
ain't a party without Old Dominion I
tell you what uh what do y'all look
forward to coming to these things
especially the ACM well just like that
got to see how to Tyler you know you see
everyone that you know that you don't
get to see all year round and it's just
kind of the pool is pretty cool went to
the pool yesterday
had a couple of ranch Waters oh what's
this all right I love you got to stay
hydrated gotta get the vitamin D you
know oh Memory Lane y'all it's such a
jam thank you how do you keep the hits
coming to us I don't know I don't know
how we do it
I was gonna say I was surprised you
didn't like go like well we're a musical
Geniuses that's that's really the only
way I don't want to you know I didn't
want to let him that I knew
but you are though you're also nominated
for group of the Year again this year
you're hoping to make way for another
statue on a bookshelf that would be
wonderful we would gladly welcome more
more statues yeah how's life on the road
y'all I feel like y'all are always on
the road I mean we're out there a lot
but we love to do it and really I mean
the chance to like go see all these fans
especially after uh doing so many
opening slots now that we're like
headlining again it's really great I
know because y'all were on Kenny
Chesney's was it Kenny Chesney I'm like
they're all kind of bubbling together
and I'm thinking this was like I felt
like I was at a festival at that concert
you know because it's like how do you
pick Hugo's first next but y'all are on
the road and uh Tyler's gonna be hitting
the road with you who else is joining
along the way it's different in
different cities so like chase is on
some of them Priscilla blocks on some of
them Riley Morgan's out there with us so
it's a bunch of different people now
we're gonna forget somebody
hopefully catch up with you backstage
after you have a trophy in your hands
and maybe a little bit more Ranch water
in your system yes yes right now it's
hot in here yeah I know bro
get out of here I didn't say I was
hotter than you I just said you did you
did
thank you so much
[Music]
foreign